Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a new first Look teaser
for House of the Dragon Season 2
With all the dragonseeds,
the new dragonriders
that Rhaenyra and Daemon are trying to use
so that they can activate
all the extra dragons
they have access to on Dragonstone.
So we'll break it all down
If you're new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
they'll be filming
House of the Dragon Season
two episodes for a while,
so we'll be getting more footage soon.
And I'm in the middle of secret Invasion
episodes.
Emilia Clarke, mother of Dragons
from Game of Thrones, is on that show
now we have Kit Harington and Emilia
Clarke inside the Marvel Universe.
We'll have to see if they ever wind up
having a reunion between those characters
in future Marvel movies.
But the first big new character is Addam
Velaryon, played by Clinton Liberty,
which confirms that it won't just be laenor
velaryon returning under a secret
false name.
Addam Velaryon is a character
from the books
the scene that they're filming is of him
getting ready to claim laenor's
former Dragons seasmoke.
They're using a lot of visual effects
like the actual dragon
is done in post-production.
That's why you see all the blue
screen effects here.
seasmoke has been living on driftmark
since Laenor took off earlier in the
timeline, he couldn't take him with him
because he would have instantly
been identified as laner.
That's why he shaved his head off to
so people wouldn't see his white hair.
laenors
whole thing is that he didn't want to be
part of the royal family just in general.
Like he said, he'd
had enough of this entire poor family.
He didn't want to inherit high tide
or his father's title.
He didn't want to participate
in the Dance of the Dragons,
the Targaryen Civil war between Rhaenyra
in the Greens and because he was married
to Rhaenyra,
he would have theoretically inherited
the Iron Throne like he would have been
the King of Westeros.
more like king consort.
But you get the idea.
so we wanted nothing to do with that.
He took the option that Rhaenyra denied
to Christian Cole earlier
when they were younger,
like Cristen Cole
astronaut to run away with him
in secret to the east.
She was like hard pass, but laners like,
you know what?
I'm going to take that option.
I'm going to run off
Adam Velaryon story in season
two will be pretty close to the books.
He's one of Corlys Velaryon's bastards
who up to this point had just been serving
as a member of his house's
military in the War of the Steppe stones
in the lesser battles that happened later
in the timeline up to present day,
the callers had been away
fighting to continue
just keeping their control over the step
stones in that trade route That was why
Rhaeny's had been so pissed off at him
when he returned after he'd been injured.
Because after they thought later falsely
had died, corners took off for the step
stones and spent all those years
avoiding dealing with laners death
by trying to keep the step stones.
Adam was there for all of that.
Given his age, he's
a little bit younger than laner velaryon,
but not that much younger.
all these dragons, these in general,
they're all meant to be bastards,
either of Targaryens or Velaryons.
they'll have certain amounts
of valyrian blood
that are in them enough
so that they can bond with dragons.
but the other funny thing is
it is a good example of how much that
their family sleeps around in general.
so when Ranieri and Daemon are looking for
dragons leads anyone with enough valyrian
blood in their veins
who can ride a dragon,
Adam becomes their choice to take laners.
Former dragons see smoke
and because he's now Corlys
Velaryon's only natural born progeny,
Even though Addam is his bastard,
he also becomes Corlys' heir
to high tide and his title.
so he is a pretty important character.
Before this
You have to remember
like we're talking about fake heirs.
Lucerys was set to inherit
high tide in the title
because his older brother Jacaerys is
was the heir apparent to the iron throne
and would become
the next king of Westeros.
So the younger brother
would inherit everything else,
even though it was a very open secret
amongst the different houses, the Greens
and the blacks in the show, like
everybody knew that he wasn't laenor's son.
He was a strong boy, quote unquote.
But they were just continuing to keep up
appearances to prevent a larger scandal.
there was an entire episode
that dealt with that, like,
there is no way that that boy
is part of my bloodline.
the ironic thing, though,
is that by the end of season one,
they revealed that Alicent and the Greens
had always planned to simply put
Rhaenyra aside and have aegon the second
Inherit the Iron Throne
no matter what had happened
there was always going to be a coup.
But alicent just disagreed
with the rest of the Greens
like her father and the rest of the Greens
about how that would go down.
Like we're going to put Aegon the second
on the Iron throne no matter what
this next new Dragonrider
character is Kieran Bew,
who's playing
Hugh Hammer also noticed the white hair.
He's a Targaryen bastard
who was the son of another Targaryen
bastard
living as a blacksmith on Dragonstone.
When the dance of the Dragons get started,
most people like that were just
regular members of their military,
like low level members of their military.
one, no one in the books knew who
his right born
ancestor was in the official royal family.
Like, where did his line come from Because
he's the son of a Targaryen bastard.
It would have been his grandfather.
At least it would've
been someone from Major in Amy's time.
But the thing is that Amy's never had
any bastards of his own.
Like he was fairly chaste
amongst other targaryens in major famously
was not able to have a male son
at least with any of the women
that he married officially.
so it's always possible
that he descends from one of Meg
or Amy's children
because at a certain point you have way
more targaryens
running around and sleeping around to.
but the idea is that
he's at least like 20 25% target.
And so the whole idea is that
you don't need to be mostly of Targaryen
blood to write dragons.
You just need a little bit of Targaryen
or Valyrian blood.
In the case of Velaryon,
one of his big nicknames in the books
is also the Betrayer.
I won't get too far
into the weeds on that.
What happens with his characters?
Because there are a lot of spoilers.
There are some big twist
with his characters.
But I fully expect then to adapt
all the big stuff from his storyline
as well as the other Dragon
Seeds storylines.
he winds up claiming vermithor who's
the oldest and biggest living dragon after
Vega during this part of the timeline,
he's almost 100 years old, right now.
In present day.
We saw Daemon at the end of season
one going to rouse him inside the dragon.
Man, this is the separate part
of the Dragonstone Island where they keep
all the dragons and where the dragon
keepers keep all the dragon eggs.
Like they basically hatch
and keep all the dragons here.
they got into this a little bit during
season one, like these dragon keepers.
They're meant to be completely separate
order apart
from the Targaryen family,
that's very insular.
They always speak in high Valyrian notice
that they don't speak and other languages
just high valyrian because that's
the language that the Dragons understand.
so their loyalty sort of supersedes
any one.
Targaryen in particular,
with the exception of the King
at any given moment for example, earlier
in season one, earlier in the timeline
when Daemon stole one of the dragon eggs
from the Dragon man,
they got really pissed off
and immediately told the king.
So his brother Vizier
has got really pissed off.
so had Daemon
not been the brother of the king.
He probably would have been killed
immediately.
Stealing a dragon egg
is like one of the worst things
that you could possibly do in Westeros.
they're more precious to the targaryens
than gold.
Essentially, they're like nuclear weapons.
before this vermithor had
been the dragon of King Jaehaerys
His grandfather,
who we saw at the beginning of season one,
no one had ridden vermithor
since his death.
Much earlier in the timeline.
and just to do the dragon lineage like
where did all these dragons come from?
Vermithor was hatched by Meraxes,
the former dragon of egg on the Aegon The Conquerors'
Sister Wife Rhaenys Princess
Rainey is on the show right now.
It was named for her.
Rainey's, and Miramax's died
just after the War of Conquest,
when Aegon united the Six Kingdoms and
Dawn by Dawn as troops who used a scorpion
like one of those big weapons
that you saw at the end of the main show,
Take down her Dragon.
And she died in the fall.
the idea is that
Miramax's is like the progenitor of pretty
much all the dragons that you wind up
seeing on the show right now.
And later in the timeline, Ultimately.
no one knows who hatched the Wild Dragons,
but they're going to be featured
during season two as well.
but like Dangerous Dragons in present day
came from a clutch of eggs
from dreamfyre
and dreamfyuyre was hatched by meraxes.
so, even though Dangerous Moniker
is the mother of dragons.
Technically Miramax's is the real mother
of all dragons that we see on the show.
Both shows.
but she's more like the grandmother and
great grandmother of the later Dragons.
Speaking of the wild dragons, though,
this woman is probably nettles.
I'm not sure who's playing her.
Let me know in the comments
if you think you know who this is.
But she's a Velaryon bastard
who's born to a hooker on Driftmark.
Given her features and age, I'd say she's
one of Corlys Velaryon's bastards
because he does have a couple bastards
or the bastards of his brother
before his brother died.
She grew up homeless.
So when we're near a side tracks
or down like other dragons seeds
who successfully bond with dragons,
all those people gain new titles
and honors as dragonriders
because they become like
the most powerful fighters in the world
because they have dragons now.
nettles winds up bonding with the sheep
stealer, the only wild dragon, the three
who anyone's able to claim
even though people attempt to claim
cannibal and Gray ghost.
I'm sure they'll have a funny WTF moment
like this on the show
where people try to claim them
and they wind up getting eaten.
So they're a bunch of people
they find with
at least a little Targaryen blood
or rumored to have Targaryen
blood that attempt to claim dragons
and wind up getting maimed or eaten.
but even though Cannibal and Gray
ghost don't get official writers,
they're still active
during the dance of Dragons.
They just do their own thing.
Nobody can order them around
because at least at this point
of the timeline, as far as we know,
No one has one of those special
valyrian horns that can command dragons
like Euron Greyjoy
eventually finds later in the timeline.
Nettles also winds up
becoming one of Daemon's lovers.
So she's a really huge character.
Just in general,
this other guy with the white hair
is Ulf White, played by Leon Ogden.
he's another Targaryen bastard
who had been living on Dragonstone
as their family's man at arms
when the Dance of the Dragons began
just like Hugh Hammer,
no one really knows which member
of the official royal family
his line comes from.
but it either comes from Maegor's line
or he comes from one of the children of
Amy's and make or of most of the bastards
that they wind up finding on the show
are like the grandsons of official members
of the Targaryen family.
seems to imagine the target
and that they came from
is much, much older or has already died.
I'm sure there'll be a lot of jokes
about this during season two
and they go around looking for dragons.
These because there were a few members
in the history of their household
that were super chaste, like Jaehaerys
The first didn't have any masters,
But at least a few of his children
famously slept around all over the place.
So some of the targaryens are like
Daemon in Aegon the 2nd like even Aegon
the 2nd who's still very young
and they just put on the Iron
Throne, has at least a few bastards.
One of them that we saw during season one.
there's even a rumor in the books
that the series had a bastard
who survived to adulthood
and is now like a much older man.
We'll see if that show pays
off. The rumor. But.
I don't know who this second woman
in the white hair is meant to be.
If she'll be another Targaryen bastard
from Dragonstone in the books.
Nettles is the only female dragon seed
that we know about.
So this is a completely new character.
Or they just changed the character
from the books.
But let me know in the comments
if you think you know who she's playing.
be they're going to be filming for
a while, so we'll get more footage soon.
I'll do more Easter Egg
videos and breakdowns as soon as we do,
Make sure to enable words for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
and bigger Reminder Mother of Dragons
Coming Back Again during Secret Invasion
Episode 3. There's
big plans for her in the Marvel Universe.
I'll talk about that
during my Secret Invasion videos.
It is really funny
seeing Kit Harington and Emilia Clarke
show up in the same franchise, though
there was a very brief Game of Thrones
reunion between Kit
Harington and Richard Madden
during the Eternals movie.
They like a funny stand off moment,
paying homage to their scene
in Game of Thrones season one
when they said
they would see each other again
and he'd be dressed all in black.
And sure enough, he became
the Black Knight in the Marvel Universe.
click.
Here for that
other brand new House of the Dragon Season
two teaser and new footage, and click here
for that teaser for the Jon Snow
Game of Thrones sequel series.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!